welcome to the March 2023 Meetup
hope everyone is excited for a uh an
excellent talk
um before we dive in what we always do
first thing
jobs if you are if you have a job you're
looking to hire for
jump into the and my hack our Meetup in
the
nyhackr.slack.com and there's a link for
to my hackcard.org there is a jobs
channel it's called jobs Dash postings
or roughly that some version of those
plurals and you can post your jobs there
so if you're looking to hire someone go
to job Dash postings at the my hack our
slack if you're looking to get hired go
to that same link and see who's posting
I know we just had um something posted
the other day there's a few posted each
week look for cool jobs or add jobs to
it
I myself am always looking for shiny
developers Linux experts and sales sales
people so um find me if you're looking
to hire I can talk about here at the
Meetup I don't have to uh post it well I
do post it um but luckily I'm on the
screen for those of you who are not on
screen hop over to the slack Channel and
post your job
uh we'll put a link to that in the chat
in a little bit
as always we have pizza at this Meetup
let's see what I got today
I got into a place called antimose it's
been sitting in my house for about 10
minutes so the cheese lock is already
solidified not a lot of oil dripping we
look at the back side we see some decent
Charming you could tell somebody to
Guess that oven and I'm looking forward
to eating this
so um one day we'll have pizza in person
together again and I'll be very excited
to see when we get all you together in
the meantime let me know where you got
your pizza or other food from for this
Meetup uh let me know where you got it
from let me know what you're eating if
you made it yourself or if you got it
from some awesome place near you I know
we have people coming in from all over
so send us a message let us know
also besides this Zoom chat you could
also go into my hack our slack and chat
in the monthly of monthly Meetup chat is
the name of the channel it's called
monthly Dash Meetup Dash chat you can go
in there to ask questions of our speaker
you go in there to talk about your food
you're eating let us know
uh before we get started before we do a
few more announcements I would like to
um I would like to introduce hanaro uh
coming to us from the UT Austin Macomb
School of Business they are sponsoring
this Meetup so we're back in person
they'll be they will be providing the
pizza and they would like to tell us a
little bit about their program they have
running right now so I'll let honaro go
ahead and tell us about UT's analytics
program at the School of Business
all right well uh thank you for uh
giving me this space and
um what I would like to talk about today
is about our msba program for working
professionals
and uh what this program is about is a
version of our full-time msva program
but uh stretched in time so that it
allows people to keep their jobs while
they can take the msva program so before
uh getting into any more details I will
tell you what is the msba program the
msba
uh is a program a master of science
programming which we combine business
Analytics
uh
machine learning I'm sorry but machine
learning AI statistics optimization with
uh business uh knowledge and and what we
do is we teach students to leverage data
science and
analytics analytics data science to
quantify business trade-offs
so we have a focus on business but we
have a Quant focus on business
for example
if you go into a scrape data science
programs you'll learn the stats DML AI
optimization and the like that's that's
cool if you go to an MBA program in our
school we are going to talk about
business trade-offs what happens if you
segment the market this or that way what
happens if you increase the price uh and
so on
uh in this program we joined both
domains and what we do is we still uh
teach our students the data science part
and then we ask our students to apply it
to quantify not to explain and quantify
uh the the trade-offs for example we're
not just going to give you a trivial
example we're not just going to say well
if price increases uh then demand is
going to go down well we know we need to
figure out by how much and then what
happens to your demand after that where
is it going is it going to your
competitor is it going to your other
products uh then after that what are you
going to do to your uh inventories in
the in the distribution chain
um the distribution channels how are you
going to affect the capacity of your
production facilities and supply chain
contracts and the like so we we take a
business view
of the problem but we teach our students
to Leverage
the mlai stats and optimization so
we train our students to go end to end
in a in an analytics project that means
we train our students to uh
create their own data sets that means
dealing with the I.T infrastructure of
the firm distributed processing systems
the cloud all of that stuff
all the data that you need then execute
algorithms maybe be part of a larger
analytic scheme with other uh data
science Specialists and then take it
back to the business
explain your Solutions in business terms
and sell Business Solutions to the
basically the people responsible for the
business silos so that's what we call
end to end this is a 23 month program
and what we have done is is we have gone
through a great length to separate what
is best learned
from a video and we have created that
video for example some some of the
technical content is better conveyed
through a video because you can listen
then you can rewind and listen again
until you understand it perfectly do an
example and so on so that can be done as
synchronously and online
but then we meet for example in this
case on Tuesday afternoons and to use
the evenings and what we do is we have a
face-to-face session presume uh a live
session with zoom giving our students
the opportunity to interact with the
instructors to ask questions
and and get into the details into the
gray areas of the business questions
that we're trying to address
so it's a combination of asynchronous
learning combined with synchronous live
learning and that all of that takes
place over a period of 23 months we have
stretched the content our full our
full-time program is 10 months long
um what we are doing is we are we are
delivering the same material with the
same level of rigor so we cannot expect
you to have a full-time job and take
this program in the same amount of time
what we are doing is we're stretching
the time to 23 months
um in essence in a nutshell I think
that's the description of the program
Gerald I think I have already exhausted
the time that you have given me I don't
want to abuse the opportunity uh but I
will be glad to send you more
information or to address any questions
that you may have
uh for for this program we still have
one more admission and deadline uh later
in April for the first class of uh the
msba programs for working professionals
great thank you for being here I know
you shared your email address so Nicole
will put that in the chat and we'll send
it to people here uh for more people who
want more information please please feel
free to email him and we also have a
link in on the Meetup description not to
your email address but to your program
uh so that'll go out to all that's
already gone out to all the users and
we'll make sure that goes into follow-up
I'll link to the program and your email
will keep to the group there's this
group that's actually here that way
you're not getting 15 000 people with
your email address
um but yeah so hopefully we'll get it
we'll get at this group and if any
analyze any more questions the link is
in the webinar chat and we will post the
his email in there as well
so thank you very much for being here
and everyone who's interested in this
program go check it out if again if you
want more information email
thank you
very welcome very welcome
speaking I I mentioned just very passing
there 15 000 members we're about to hit
15 000.
um we're we're
14.6 right now so it's very nice to see
this group grow from
20 people back in 2009 to almost 15 000
now so it's a very exciting for this
group and folks when we hit 15 000 I'm
sure we'll send out an email blast and
we'll find some way to celebrate how
we're going to celebrate I don't know
we'll find something I'm not sure what
we're gonna do so I'm looking forward to
that that day folks there's a big
milestone when we hit 10 we're getting
15 now and hopefully we'll just keep
growing more interesting people
so part of this meetup group and how it
is expanded it's expanded into other
events and workshops we put on in
conferences and we just announced
yesterday that 2023 New York R
conference will be July 11th through
14th
we have workshops we're doing two days
of workshops this year
um July 11th and 12th the actual
conference itself the 13th and 14th uh
we have we have a few speakers up on the
site right now about a quarter of them
maybe a little more and we have more and
more being announced um very soon we're
just waiting for people to confirm
you'll see who's already there we have
workshops from Max and Rob Hindman
we have speakers
um like Austin matumi and Wes McKinney
uh it's a really great lineup and those
of you who've been to the conference
before you know how much fun it is you
know how much you learn really we're
really looking forward to that when you
want to learn more go to rstats.ai
um you just go there you'll see all the
conferences but you can go to
specifically rstats.ai nyr
and if you want to get tickets you you
could go to the tickets page and put in
code NY hack R for 20 discount
we'll be sending an email blast to the
whole group but I was excited to
announce it today and at the end of The
Talk today before the Q a we will give
away a free ticket either in person or
virtual for nyr people have both options
so very excited to announce that
we will also be announcing in the next
month or two this year's argov which
will be taking place in October a little
change from the normal November December
time frame it'll be in October more
information to follow about our gov
if you can't wait until October for our
gov but you've already gone to myr in
July we're putting on a general purpose
data conference called D4 taking place
in Tampa August 23rd through 25th
now we're excited for that it's our
first
um uh General data not just programming
or statistics it's a little mishmash of
everything if you want to learn more
about that you can go to d4con dot IO
and again the discount code is good for
there too and my hack R will get you 20
off of that conference and we will also
give away a ticket for that either
virtual or in person
um after the talk but before the Q a
for the next few months we have more
meetups planned but we need your help we
do it in person when we can well we do a
hybrid in person or virtual when we can
and virtual only when the situation
arises
in April
we are looking for a venue to host Us in
New York city so if you have space and
you want to host the Meetup send me a
message you can find me at
gerrylander.com you can find me Atlanta
analytics.com you can find me on
LinkedIn you can find me on Twitter you
can find me on GitHub if you need to all
right find me anywhere we're looking for
a space for April to host the Meetup we
have a space lined up for May so we're
good for that but we need spaces every
month so if you want to do it as a
one-off you want to do it consistently
or a few times a year let me know be in
touch we'd love to have you participate
in the Meetup in that way
and one last thing if you have questions
for our speaker since you obviously
can't ask on screen
ask either in the zoom chat or
preferably in the Meetup in the Meetup
slack go to the NY hack our slack go to
the monthly Meetup chat Channel and ask
questions there and at the end I will
collate and ask our speaker your
questions
so hope everyone has enjoyed their pizza
and is ready to learn a lot our next
speaker I help teach him R and now uses
python so I chase them away
um but very excited to have him I've
known I've known him for looking at the
year
12 years 11 years
roughly that kind of basic math right
uh been a very long time
he's spoken at our conference before and
very excited to have him speak at our
Meetup about this really awesome python
package he's put together which he'll
show you how to use from with an r or
without R if you want everyone please
give a very good Emoji welcome to Niels
thanks Jared it feels kind of like a
little bit of a homecoming year
um
I'll share a little bit of this uh in a
second but yeah I'll
basically talk about how to use Pandera
in R using reticulate that's
kind of the the topic for today and
um I was actually anticipating having a
whole section on sort of gotchas and
things that you have to be careful about
but
based on the things that I've
I've tried testing out like things just
work so you know kudos to the reticulate
maintainers and others it's uh yeah
things just kind of work out of the box
so
you know
kind of rare in in the software I would
say
so who am I
um right now I'm the chief ml engineer
at the union AI Union AI is a company
that essentially builds tools for data
and machine learning and
um we have a certain opinion on this
uh basically we built this platform
called flight I'm not sure anyone's
heard of it we're still kind of working
on our our marketing there but flight is
a kubernetes native workflow
orchestrator so think you know airflow
um
or prefect that this is in Python land I
guess targets would be uh somewhat of a
kind of pipelining language that I can
think of in R off the top of my head
um but I'm also the author of Pandera
and Union ml these are both python
packages that I've been working on for
the past
few years uh Pandera more so than Union
ml
um that was uh I think released last
year
um but my background is in biology and
public health uh with a little bit of uh
you know dance minor there uh sprinkled
in from college and I kind of stumbled
into data science machine learning and
programming as Jared mentioned
my time in grad school doing Public
Health was kind of the first time I I
dabbled in programming and I I sort of
fell in love with it and um yeah well
here I am today
uh my first language was technically
Java in college but that was like a
semester so I don't remember too much of
it
um when I kind of picked up programming
you know later on I learned Python and R
in parallel
um so
it was a little bit confusing at first
but I think it it sort of helped just um
teach me about uh both languages and you
know
I haven't used R in a while admittedly
but there was a time that I I did um
kind of
use it every day for you know shiny and
and deep plier and all the all that the
good tidy verse stuff
all right so I'm gonna break this talk
up into two sections
um the first section I'll kind of give
you a Pandora crash course in pure
python
um I'll introduce you to some of the
Core Concepts in Pandera which include
schemas
um checks
um check constraints and uh
essentially give you a mental model of
how Pandera Works
um kind of in its in its native language
how people tend to use it
um
what it's meant for what it's not meant
for
and the second part of the talk I'll
switch over to using reticulate and kind
of showing you how to use Pandera
um
with with r
so without further Ado I'm gonna go to
this try try Pandora link this is
actually in the um
the repos documentation so if you go to
Pandora oops really big
yeah if you go to
pandora.readthedocs.io
there's a little tab here called
trypandera and it'll take you
essentially to a jupyter notebook
powered by Jupiter light and so this is
a kind of in-browser experience
um for Jupiter notebooks
Okay so
what is Pandera it's an open source
framework
um and you basically visit you can
Define schemas for data frame like
objects and integrate them into your
Pipelines
uh really the main value of Pandera is
articulated maybe I can articulate it
through uh why I built it in the first
place so
at a prior job I was just working with
data frames all the time so I do a SQL
query I would cache the result somewhere
and I would start hacking away at it
cleaning it up typically for some kind
of modeling purpose
so
I would get bitten many times about uh
been many times
with data frames that had types that I
didn't expect them to be so I expected a
column to be a daytime and it was a
string
or I expected certain values to be in my
numeric column and not others right so
like positive numbers and there would be
a negative number in there and I
wouldn't catch it until later
um so at least in pandas right you have
this
very flexible powerful mutable data
frame object and you can pretty much do
anything with it
within the bounds of the the DSL
um so
this happened so many times that I
kind of got sick of it and decided to
write Pandera
um and as you'll see later the the kind
of the design decision for the way you
write schemas is very much reminiscent
of uh how you would write a pen pandas
data frame
and it's also fairly readable
so the first thing we'll look at is
how to define a schema there are
actually two flavors of how to define a
schema the the
thing I'm going to show you now is the
second flavor
um and not sure who here is is kind of
bilingual in r in Python but you know
data classes and pedantic are all kind
of all the craze these days
um at least in Python so
this is how you define a Pandora schema
using what I'll call the class-based
method
so what I'm doing here is
I'm inheriting from this class called
Data frame model
and I'm defining this class called
schema
and it has two attributes item and price
and as you can see here it's just very
transparent about what is in what's
supposed to be in this in this data
frame right so
item is a string it has two allowable
values apple and orange and when I call
schema.validate which is the main
function main method by which you
validate data
what course equals true is going to do
is it's going to try to coerce the
incoming
data frame
into the specified types here
so it's going to try to coerce whatever
the item column happens to be into a
string and it's going to try to coerce
whatever price happens to be into a
float
and so the you know the kind of words
for this would be parsing and validation
right so parsing takes raw data
transforms it into some in some way into
some kind of like desired
format data type
um
form more generally
and
so that's what in combination with the
type specified here
um
a worse equal true equals true will
attempt to do this type coercion
so that's a parsing bit
the validation part is validation
essentially is here's my data
do a fancy assertion or do an assertion
on it you don't transform it you
basically just say this these are the
properties let me know if one of those
properties has been violated
so what we're saying here is price needs
to be positive
and
the item needs to be in this finite set
of things
Okay so we've defined a schema
how do we actually use this in in kind
of like a real world pipeline
well there's a syntax here that um
may not be familiar to everyone but this
is
basically the type hinting syntax in in
Python so this came out in python36037
but essentially you can you can State
what the types are of
um the inputs and outputs of a function
and what Pandera gives you is this
decorator
called check types
and we'll go over what lazy equals true
is in a second but
basically what I'm saying is I'm
declaring a transform data function
it takes in a data data frame
um don't worry about the syntax too much
this is basically like a pandas data
frame of the Pandera version of it and
this essentially says the data frame
that's incoming to this function needs
to conform to the schema that we defined
up here
without the check types decorator this
is simply a type hint so in Python
um
this won't do anything at runtime it
will simply uh
like it won't yeah it won't do anything
it'll only do something called
static type linting
um kind of
using tools like my pie
static type linters
it will
try to analyze statically analyze your
code and see whether you know the inputs
that you're invoking transform data with
are of the correct type
so this isn't super relevant for for us
because we actually want to do runtime
validation
so with the check types decorator we can
see actually that this function does
nothing right so let's go ahead and
Define it
and now I'm going to just Define some
valid data so just a data frame of two
rows
first item is an apple like 50 cents the
second item is an orange 75 cents not
sure how much these go for these days
but if we pass this into transform data
it doesn't really do anything right
um
because transform data returns nothing
but under the hood
actually
Pandera has called schema.validate on
the data frame even before the like this
function body has started executing
so to show you what this looks like with
invalid data
I'm going to introduce some corrupt data
here so here's a typo on the Apple item
and then there's just like some crazy
negative value here with for the price
and so what's happening Happening Here
is
I'm doing a try accept
so I'm going to try executing this
function
and if I find a schema schema errors
exception
I'm going to catch it and I'm going to
display the failure cases
and this is this is really how many
people that I've seen and you know code
that I've I've stalked various repos uh
that use Pandora and just to get a sense
of how people are using it
um
and this is
one of the the core things the the core
of ways of interacting with Pandora is
it's
it basically
allows you to add kind of guard rails
around your functions or you know
if you have a long pipeline of functions
right you can add a guard rail at the
input of that pipeline the first step
and then it does a bunch of stuff you
might not want to type check everything
at every intermediate step but then at
the end of your pipeline say you're
writing to a database
you know before you write you want to
make sure certain things are certain
properties are are true
and so this is one of the core
mechanisms by which you can add these
guard rails
and
essentially if uh if one of those
properties has been violated in this
case two properties
with the lazy equals true
argument up here and check types
what it's going to do it's it's going to
try applying all the validation checks
that we've defined so to go back up here
first it's going to you know coerce the
types and it would throw an error if the
the raw values are not coercible
but it's going to apply this check and
this check
and in this case there are errors in
both checks right and it's gonna
it's gonna report all the checks
possible
if lazy equals equals fault false this
would raise a schema error which is a
different error type and it'll just
raise as early as possible as soon as it
hits the first
um property violation
so
as you can see here this schema error is
exception contains a failure cases
attribute and this failure cases
attribute
Pandera takes a lot of care trying to
pick out where exactly the error error
occurred
so in this case you know if we
look at this this um
invalid data data frame
right it's on the zeros and the first
index and we can see here that this
matches
um so this is useful if you have you
know say A medium small to medium data
set you know kind of like fits in a
pandas data frame
um
it's a memory and you want to know
exactly where every single failure case
occurred
another way you can use schemas is you
can simply invoke it in line so you know
say you have a function here this
schema.validate call is essentially
equivalent
to if I got rid of this
and this and I did this
so schema.validate Returns the valid
data if all the checks passed and then
raises an exception if the
um the checks did not pass
so that's kind of like the kind of
programming model of Pandera a lot of at
least in Python a lot of data validation
tools
their purpose is to
collect a validation report
um and so they focus a lot on very nice
kind of informative kind of HTML
documents and and other kind of
artifacts
Pandera is really kind of a developer
tool where you know it's up to you what
you want to do with these these failure
cases right so this is the Syntax for if
I want to catch the failure cases if I
want to kind of like filter out because
I have the indexes right I can like
filter out all the invalid data and then
produce a kind of a valid data frame
under the schema so it's really up to up
to the data scientists or the mle or the
data engineer to figure out what they
want to do with this
um and Pantera doesn't do too much by
way of
coming up with a
kind of like aesthetic reports
this part
is about thinking about schemas as data
quality checkpoints this is what I
mentioned earlier right with the
pipeline you don't want to necessarily
validate everything there is a runtime
cost to this since
um you are executing code that
is essentially a fancy assertion
but here's here's another kind of mental
model for you to to kind of chew on
so here's just a redefinition of the
schema we were already familiar with
with Pandora with this particular
class-based syntax you can actually
inherit
from the schema and Define a new
transform schema
and it's going to inherit all of the
properties
of the original the parent schema
but you can express additional if this
is like the additive nature of
inheritance where you can add additional
attributes
to this transform transform schema
and this kind of gives you the reader or
maintainer of like a data pipeline
a sense of okay there's a function
somewhere that's actually below here but
is it function in the abstract that will
take this as input and produce this as
output and you can immediately see just
visually in your in your code base okay
the input has item in price of these
types and then the function needs to add
an expiry column to this of type time
stamp and maybe some other properties
so as I as you can see on this page this
is the function
um it's very simple it just assigns a
new column to the data frame
so
if we run this it seems to be happy
this is great actually so
um
this isn't actually doing the runtime
checks right
but if I say have a bug in my code this
is a toy example obviously I just have a
typo here
but you can imagine you know more
complex piece to the pipeline more
complex functions
so here what I'm doing is I'm adding the
check types decorator again so this will
run time check
this input and then also run type and
check the output of the function
and if I run this
right the the error is a lot kind of
more alarming if I don't do the try
accept
right it's like going to throw this
error
but just for
the purposes of this presentation I'm
doing the try try accept pattern
and we can see here and there are
complains the the check was a column and
data frame
and the failure cases
um
oh this is actually a bug this should be
this thing okay I'll need a file an
issue for this but this this is saying
the this is saying
actually the expiring column was
expected but
um there was a there was a bug in oh
there's a typo in there
um so essentially what this gives you is
a function that just always checks the
data and in a lot of cases where there
isn't such a big runtime cost say it's
you know a data frame of a couple
thousand rows even tens of thousands
um this shouldn't take too long and
you're you can be kind of safe that
under the assumptions of your schema
that the data you're passing in is
correct
so
just to give you a little bonus uh the
the object-based API
this is the API that was the original
API for Pandera
um
schema is the the this class-based
syntax is essentially a uh like
syntactic sugar this thing will
essentially you know compile down to a
data frame schema object
um so just to show you that this is the
the class
if you call two schema it's going to
convert this into a data frame schema
object and so this is actually the thing
that does a lot of the heavy lifting
it's the like original specification
um the reason you might want to use the
object-based API instead of the
class-based one is
you can apply imperative logic to it so
you can say schema.ad columns right so
this is equivalent to the
um transform schema thing right whereas
this syntax is simply additive you can't
once you inherit from schemas you can't
really remove properties
um without some hacking
um whereas the objective API it's very
natural you can add columns
you can remove columns you can you know
update the properties in this case of
the price into an integer
um and you can similarly call
schema.validate on this as well
okay so I hope that was informative uh
give you a sense of you know how Pandora
looks in Python
um and
here are a bunch of features it's fairly
feature-rich at this point uh it
supports regex pattern matching for
columns so you know you don't have to
you have a data frame of like a thousand
columns it's like
named similarly right so call underscore
one call underscore two you can Define
you know a single column schema
component and apply that by saying reg x
equals true so there's a bunch of
different stuff and I'll actually show
you in the next part I'll hop back onto
the quarto slides
um
sorry how am I doing in time
you're still good okay awesome
okay
so next part of the talk is Pandera with
r
and um
this was an interesting yeah Adventure
uh I kind of had to ramp up my vs code
Editor to to use R
um
just kind of as an extra challenge I
hadn't used R studio in a while and you
know I just wanted to see how how the vs
code support was so that was that was
fun
um so with reticulate
all of this by the way is is written in
quarto and um at the end I'll show you
where the repo is and I'm using a conda
environment
um just because it's easier to manage
both R and python dependencies
but before going moving forward I did
want to make this call out you know the
the kind of subtitle of this talk is
something about a highly unnecessary but
interesting uh case study in in our
python interoperability
so it's highly unnecessary because there
are actually python packets or sorry our
packages that uh do data validation
already
um so
you know there's the validate package
which I think has been around for a
while there's Point Blank
um so there are probably others but
these two have been in my radar for a
while and actually I kind of took
inspiration from these two uh when I
built Pandera maybe four or five years
ago
so
just a shout out to the authors and
maintainers here
um the syntax is quite nice so uh and it
integrates nicely with kind of like
the D plier and
um
the the r ecosystem
but you know if if one can do something
it's worth trying so
here we are we're basically going to
define a Pandera schema in in a python
runtime and with reticulate and Porto
you essentially have
access to these these objects
so um
here's the schema you're familiar with
apples and oranges and prices
and here's some python data that we're
going to test out
here's some R data
so we're defining a data frame same
thing
um items items and and the price
associated with each one
so this is cool uh
I thought there would
be some like Nan issues here but somehow
they they were all handled
um so this pi
I don't know what to call it uh object
I'm just gonna say my R is a little
rusty so if you see our code here that
looks weird or not idiomatic uh please
uh please uh pardon pardon the uh that
we're looking our code so okay you have
this Pi object and you can essentially
access a bunch of attributes that are
defined
um
back here right so we Define schema and
python data
so
I'm gonna straight up you know try to
validate the python data and use the
schema in the r runtime and you know you
can see that works
and our data frames right so this this
this guy right here our data
we're gonna feed it into the schema
validate method
in Python
and I actually still need to read read
more about this but I unders for my
understanding
what is happening here is there is a
python sub process or runtime embedded
in the the r you know runtime
and what reticulate is doing is it knows
how to serialize and deserialize
certain objects functions classes to and
from are in Python
so what's Happening Here is our data is
being converted into a pandas data frame
and then this is just the python this is
the python schema class this is the the
classes validate method and
um
it's essentially validating the
pandas data frame
giving back the results
and then converting that back into an R
data frame and that's what's being
printed out here
so
what if the data is invalid it take it
took me a little time to kind of figure
out the how to do this but
you know here's some invalid data
here's a typo in Orange and here's a
negative value so we should expect this
to complain
um
let me know if this is super you know
heretical or not but I use the try catch
you know construct here
I'm trying to validate the invalid data
I'm saying lazy equals true because you
know I wanted to apply as many checks as
it can before raising the error
and then reticulate has this nice high
last error function that will return
um like an R object that contains a
bunch of stuff and in that stuff is an
exception attribute that I'm grabbing
here
um actually a question for for everyone
here is I'm not quite sure what the
difference between an attribute access
with a dollar sign is versus this this
Adder function but uh you know this is
how I got it to work
um and then this gives me the
python schema errors exception
and um I'm
gonna make this available in the global
scope
so I know this is going to fail
and here are a few go this is a kind of
the only gotcha that I that I had with
this and this is well known of xero
versus one base indexing
so
if you recall in
back in Python land
let's go back up to this exception right
so
this failure case is data frame indexes
provides the index
um
and it's you know zero indexing right
so when I get the failure cases here so
this is exception this is exactly the
same things uh Escape exception dollar
sign dealer cases
um
first of all the row names in a r data
frame I had to remind myself their their
strings so first I need to plus one all
of the indexes
and convert it into characters
to get the failed row kind of
identifiers for this
and
um I'm just printing out the failure
cases here just to to prove to you that
uh you know it contains the right
failure cases
and you know one use case of this would
be to filter out invalid rows right so
um
unfortunately this you know there's
there is no like utility function for
this uh this this would probably be you
know something you have in your library
if you choose to
you know be crazy and use Pandora in
your in your R
um pipelines or your scripts or
notebooks
um
but when use cases okay we have the
um the failed rows
so I'm just going to filter out the
invalid data and and produce a filtered
data data frame and so we were left with
one item here that's valid
okay
the last thing I want to showcase here
is
um
synthesizing test data with Pandera I
think this is the maybe the one thing
that justifies using Pandera over you
know the r
um validation packages uh made I don't
know maybe maybe there is a data
synthesis
um library that I'm not aware of so
please do let me know
so with Pandora
you have a schema
and
you know just as a background here this
was kind of like one of the most
grueling coding experiences I I've had
kind of
at the point of writing this feature
Bandera had a lot of features already
like a lot of constraints a lot of
checks built-in checks a lot of like
different things here and there
and the idea behind this is okay we have
we've we've already defined
what valid data looks like
and I don't know about about everyone
here but I would to test kind of like my
data cleaning data processing code
you need to write unit tests you need to
write test cases
and it just became such a pain to write
mock pandas data frame uh
that mock pandas data Frame data to test
the functions right so here's my valid
data here's a happy path here like all
the things that can go wrong
um
and you want to test those cases
well
the the motivation behind this feature
was exactly this where you know if you
already know what valid data looks like
why can't we generate data from it
so you can test the happy path
and as I'll show you later you can you
know create sort of a schema spec for
something that you're fairly sure is
guaranteed to
um fail your tests right
so here's just like an example of this
where
the schema class has an example method
you give it a size and it'll generate a
data frame that's valid under the
constraints of that schema so you can
see like you have
ridiculously small prices for apples and
oranges but you know
um
this is not realistic but it'll test you
know the boundaries are of your function
pretty well
um
so
the way you might want to do this in
um in R right
is
you have this process data function this
imagine this is in your you know source
code
take some data
takes in another argument
and
essentially what this function is doing
is it's validating the data first so the
output of this will be
you know you get back in our data frame
and then we're just piping it through to
mutate and adding a stop column
so a test or this function might look
something like this
and here's the happy path right so we're
using the schema itself
we're generating five rows of data as
mock data
we're passing as just a single value in
stock so that'll kind of broadcast
throughout the shape of the data
and
um you pass it the mock data and uh
you'll do some assertions here uh
realistically but here I'm just printing
the output
so it's giving giving you some like
reasonable looking prices the items are
correct and you know the the function
did the correct thing so this is maybe
something you you might want to add to
the test
but as I mentioned earlier right
we can you know instead of handwriting
[Music]
um
multiple data frames right to test all
the different edge cases
you can create an invalid schema class
and here we have the right columns and
types but it's not constrained by apples
and oranges and it's not constrained by
greater than zero
so
when we write our test process data
error case
um we're going to create some mock data
from the invalid schema
we'll do the try catch thing again so we
can get the exception and so we can make
assertions about the failure case
and here the failure case is this is an
empty string
that occurred in the item column
and so
I've yet to figure out how to do this
actually in R but the way you would do
this in Python is actually this
is this is this whole feature is backed
by a library called hypothesis so this
is a python library that allows you to
do property-based testing so you
essentially State the properties of your
test like these are the input types
these are the expected output types and
hypothesis will generate just a bunch of
data based on those properties
and the thing is configurable but you
can set it to say like generate a
thousand examples you know she's just
gonna uh I think it's called fuzz
testing it's just going to test all
sorts of different
inputs to your to your function
um and more often than not actually
it'll find a lot of holes in your in
your implementation
um so this has been a hypothesis has
been a super helpful library at least
for me
um
so like the simplest way to do this in R
would be to do a for Loop and then to
call this example method multiple times
and each time it'll generate a different
data frame
um that is most likely invalid
Okay so
hopefully that kind of gives you a
flavor both of Pandera and then you know
reticulate if you hadn't used that
before and kind of like the magic that
happens when you
um kind of pass python objects into R
our objects into python
um
so Pandora lets you Define statistical
types for your data frames and you know
statistical types is
something I somewhat coined uh hasn't
caught on yet but the idea is you have
kind of types that are you know the
regular kind of data types right editors
floats numbers strings dates booleans
um but statistical types are interesting
because you can only really
validate it by checking the values
itself
so if you're saying this column is
normally distributed with a mean of five
and a standard deviation of 2.5
um
you don't either no you can't really
know that unless you check the value
right
um so I didn't dive into this part of
Pandora but you can write kind of these
hypothesis tests and kind of bake them
into your schemos as well
um takeaway two you can use R use it in
our with particulate
and just something if if someone
listening to this is curious you know
I'd be
uh curious to see how this can break
um and what what certain gotchas are
when either using reticulate in general
or trying to use Pandera in a horror
runtime
so I want to thank you for your time and
attention
um you can find me at Cosmic Bboy on
Twitter
the slides are up here on Union aiosss
Pandora and why hacker 2023 0-330
um the repo for Pandora is over here uh
in the union AI OSS org under Pandera
and um there's a Discord channel here uh
where you know you can join ask
questions uh
and um yeah thank you so much
thank you we'll do an emoji clap for
Neils that's all we can do with this now
we can't do real positive anymore so you
got Emoji collapse
well thank you very much thank you very
much for the talk
um I have a few questions to throw at
you
um an early side you show like a do
catch
is it possible like if you're putting
The Decorator on it just is that good
enough and it will just fail out and you
pass it invalid data and the function
just generates an error or what happens
so you're talking about
um this or wait
in in Python like this case yeah yeah
like a little lower
like so you called that function without
you try catch afterwards what would
happen just the whole function would
create an error if you had one exception
yeah exactly so if we here's the you
know recall we'll call the decorated
function with invalid data and you know
the the exception is like this you know
giant string that kind of tells you okay
um
there are different kind of error
reasons and so that there are two error
reasons that occurred are
no schema component checks so schema
components would be like Columns of a
data frame or the index of a data frame
and um
this is like a summary uh
it's like it tells you where what
contexts the error happened in so in
this case there's a column it could be a
data frame wide check as well I didn't
get into that but um yeah the error just
is just thrown and
um you know wherever this is running it
could be like in a crown job or
somewhere in the cloud and you know this
this will be the error message you see
um however you could do something like
this where it's like you know I want to
report something a little richer
I can I can raise here
um
if I choose to do so
and
um or you could use the inline syntax
and just so you could build that into
your function to check yeah exactly so
it's pretty flexible that way
cool
we have another question could you
elaborate on how the python and R output
objects interact with each other in a
quarter document
yeah yeah this was this was something I
was learning about uh literally in
preparation for this this talk so
from my best understanding so let me
just kind of hop into the the code for
this slide deck
here's my quarto doc and
you basically you know you're familiar
probably with the syntax here we have
like these code
um
code braces or code fences
and you say which run time you're using
in that code fence
um
so from my best understanding
the python code will run in that
python sub process
when you kind of like execute this
quarto document
and any object defined in the python
runtime
is available
via this this is a reticulate
um thing
I'll just call it an object I don't know
what the terminology is actually but you
can access
all of the um
things defined in that python runtime
in uh with the dollar sign notation here
um so
to answer your question kind of maybe
vaguely
essentially there are two processes
occurring there's the r and there's the
python process and what reticulate is
doing is
essentially when I'm executing our code
that relies on the python objects
it's
when I do this it essentially
serializes gives me like a
representation of of the
python object
and when I I could so essentially it
gives me like access to the classes and
functions and the methods
um kind of like in this nested fashion
um
and I can either this basically is all
from my understanding is all occurring
in Python in that in that runtime so the
python schema dot validate method is
validating the python data frame
whereas here
what's happening is
the python schema dot validate
is being fed a r data frame and what
reticulate is doing is it's converting
that our data frame into a pandas data
frame
applying that to the validate method
and gives me back the r data frame and
that's what is being printed out
um I could be wrong there though I
haven't tested this too much
and there's a follow-up
can you in Python can you do like r
dollar sign or the equivalent dollar
sign of Pi like r dot r underscore data
in Python
I believe so I I was looking at the
reticulate documentation I think it only
um it's only available in like our
markdown or or quarto
um
you there's yeah there's so I think it's
I think it is this
um so if I
do this
or yeah there's some there's some R
object we can look at the docs but it is
that is a possibility so you can
um you know use our functions as well in
your python
um code which is ridiculously cool
unfortunately I think to do this in just
a straight up python module it's that's
not possible you know I'm not sure if
that's in the works but like a kind of
reticulate python package that allows
you to do the other way around
um R2 Pi or something like that R pi two
yeah yeah yeah and so what I've seen it
doesn't work as nicely as reticulate
those
yeah yeah it's it's a much like older I
suppose uh
package and I guess it is mature like
I've seen there's a bunch of releases
for it but um yeah the syntax isn't as
um neat
okay
or I did the giveaways you had mentioned
something about data frame checks which
goes with one of our questions here can
it do a checks like the number of
columns in a data frame or the number of
rows kind of check for that
yeah you
I really need to uh
beef up kind of like the built-in checks
here the the kind of the
um
fall back for a lot of these things
is custom checks which I did not cover
but
maybe I can do that here so if you do p
pa dot data frame check yeah oops what
did it do
I can define a method here that check
rows
so there's there's a bunch of code you
have to write but the short answer to
the question is it is possible
um
I guess the the focus and the reason for
this is the focus of Pandora is to sort
of
feel more like you know like a SQL
schema right it's it's like
a SQL screening schema doesn't
outright say
how many columns and how many rows there
are
um it kind of gives you what the columns
are and what the data types of the
columns are and then Pandera will add
the additional checks stuff
um
so
short answer yes longer answer
I wish that was built in
um so you know we're taking
contributions you know
yeah
um in a similar regard can it validate
like the mean is of certain value around
a Delta I'm going to guess it's a custom
check too where like the variance of a
columnism is around a certain Delta
yeah the the plan you know the Syntax
for this
um so the check the built-in checks are
accessed via this thing
um so you know there are a bunch of
built-in checks but the syntax would be
like something like this
that I
want but yes so today you would you
would write a regular check so this
applies to you know let's say price
and you would get the series here
and so you would return sears.mane
and then you know something like that
and then it's all you need to do what
you would be done at that point you need
to go apply it it just happens now yeah
it just happens now yeah okay
cool the um the object-based gamer has a
different kind of thing so you know the
discrepancy kind of bothers me but it is
what it is at this point
um but
at this yeah this this would be like
your check goes here right and the the
expected signature is either a Boolean
um Boolean series if it took a series in
or a data frame in or a data frame
Boolean so Pandera will automatically
know okay how to handle the output and
then you know
oh massage it into a form that you know
is human readable if the error does
occur
okay
um and since you did mention a SQL
schema can this validate like something
you're using like SQL Alchemy like when
you get the results back and it checks
yes it can provided that you're reading
it into a pandas data frame
um there the integration I'm working on
right now is is with Ibis and so Ibis is
a
I believe a Voltron data West McKinney
and co uh project
and
once that's done you uh Pandera will be
able to do in database validation so you
use the SQL engine to do the thing and
then not exactly sure how to report the
error errors you know at this point
we'll have to figure that out
um probably it'll read it in as a
appendix data frame
um or have it be customizable
um a temporary table
may make sense I'm not sure yeah
and since you brought up Voltron what
about Arrow tables or pullers
yes also in in there's an issue for
these and you know
they're like very there's a few
interested parties
um I guess the last thing I'll say about
that is
I did another kind of grueling
experience like internals rewrite of
Pandera to be able to actually support
additional backends
so the idea is
just to hop down here the data frame
schema becomes kind of like so the
problem before the rewrite was the data
frame schema was both the specification
for the constraints and the validation
it implemented the validation logic so
it kind of conflated those two concerns
and the rewrite kind of decoupled those
so that you can have a generic data
frame schema spec and then just
arbitrary back ends assuming that the
spec kind of conforms to whatever the
data object is
um so any kind of tabular thing
you know we'll we'll rip that out and
make it not a pandas data frame schema
but like a table schema or something
something of that sort
um and then you'll be able to just write
arbitrary backends for it including
polars and and Ibis
yeah that'd be really cool
yeah all right so enough about things
you can support
um let's ask about things you could
Define like can you define that missing
values are allowed or are not allowed
that is here nullable equals true
great
um or false yeah so there are a bunch of
so the column object has a bunch of
built-in properties so it takes in the
data type of course these are a single
check or list of checks that are user
defined
nullable you know unique
essentially how to report duplicates
this is a panda specific thing but you
know
it's kind of General enough to say I
don't I want to report every duplicate
or just you know the first occurrence or
you know something like that
um you can say whether something is
required
um
the name is interesting because the
column can actually be used in isolation
you don't have to use it in a data frame
schema you can actually pass it a data
frame and it'll only check the column
through this name so if this name is
defined it'll check that column
um
reg x equals true will consider the
column name to be a regex pattern and
then we'll apply that and then title it
in description are kind of
uh
human readable kind of labels attached
to to components of your schema
um yeah
and then what if a column has multiple
photos see the example you showed
there's one failure in a college no no
let me take it back that's not the
question because it's what if a row has
two columns that failed their checks
yeah so that's where the whole lazy
thing comes in
um
so let's maybe go back to the invalid
data
so by default lazy equals equals to
false and so what in what happens in
this case
is it's gonna raise the first error it
sees just based on it's purely based on
like the order in which the columns are
defined at the order in which checks are
defined and it happened to
apply this is an apple orange check
first and it'll report that failure case
um
when lazy equals to true
oops
this is where the whole like try
accepting comes in but
um oh no yeah this thing
essentially what happens is it'll try to
apply all the checks
and then it'll aggregate them all into a
single
data structure which is failure cases
which is itself a data frame
so they're like you still only have two
rows but in feather cases would be
greater than one
yes okay
yeah
so if this had 100 call like the worst
case scenario is every single value is
um invalid in which case the failure
cases data frame is actually in tidy
form right so it's it's going to be not
a great data frame to work with
um especially if you have like a million
rows you have a 10 a thousand columns
and it'll be you know a billion row
failure case thing so the failure case
the number of failure cases you report
that's also configurable
um so you can say five and then it'll
only report five
okay
all right um you mentioned about it um
adding overhead how much overhead does
this add because I know like there's
always debate like in R like using
assert that like you're doing an if
check essentially each time
yeah exactly
um that's my on my to-do list is a
benchmarking exercise
um so I don't have concrete numbers
unfortunately the the main thing I will
say is it's roughly based on what it
would have the kind of informal
benchmarking I've done it's roughly
equivalent to if I had
done this like
validata Dot item dot is in apple orange
and then I assert like all these things
are true
um so it's roughly equivalent to what if
I had written them by
um
from scratch
and then as a related question I know
there's an r package like does either
validate or checkpoint or maybe it might
be a different one that
it does all the checks while you're
developing but it's actually time to run
the code it turns them all off to avoid
the overhead is that a feature you have
here
that is an issue uh
Pandera hasn't had a config file for
forever
um okay but this would be like an
environment variable or config file
thing that you just like disable
everything and then you know none of the
runtime runtime checks happen
yeah so yeah it's in the works
cool
all right
um and I think that was all the
questions we had you had a question
about attributes versus dollar signs so
if you use like object dollar sign
something like let's say it's a data
frame it's data frame dollar sign column
that you access it whereas an attribute
it's like a hidden thing about the
object
um so unless you had a list you could do
list dollar sign item in a list whereas
an attribute it's not printed by default
it's not stored in a slot and you can
only access it it's it's metadata about
the object
uh I see cool yeah that clarifies it
great all right with that we have all of
our questions asked and I'll say let's
give another round of emoji Applause to
Neils for coming giving this talk
uh thank you very much for being here
the video will be up in a few days on
the YouTube channel and
um everyone come in April we need a
space give us space for April and come
see the speaker come to the conferences
have a great time thank you everyone for
being here and again thank you to Niels
for giving this talk and thank everyone
hopefully we'll see you again soon bye
everybody
thanks so much everyone bye bye